rainbow six siege coach ellis gigg
hindle has been accused of physical and
sexual assault
by an ex-girlfriend she recently came
forward with accusations dating back to
early 2020.
this situation has heavily divided the
siege scene so i spoke with the alleged
victim as well as the greater manchester
police department
in order to bring you all of the
information available
[Music]
before i start laying out the facts of
this story a warning
this video contains a detailed rape
allegation
as well as multiple accounts of physical
and mental abuse
if those things have the potential to be
triggering for you
feel free to click off now so back on
april 30th
amy southern published a twit longer
accusing her ex-boyfriend
gig of physical and mental abuse
she recounts multiple instances where
gig allegedly harmed her
physically as well as allegations of
constant mental abuse
that drove her to contemplate suicide
quote there was one soul incident where
he shouted at me constantly for two days
to the point where i was silent and just
didn't dare say anything this resulted
in him screaming at me back at the hotel
and i locked myself in the bathroom and
contemplated taking my life for 30
minutes
he never checked in on me once he played
lego star wars on his ipad
end quote later that same day gigg
released a statement of his
own denying all of the allegations and
stating that he was fully cooperating
with police
quote i have proof that none of this is
true and will show my side and due
course but for now i'm going to let the
police do their job
end quote now i've spoken to amy and
you'll be hearing from her throughout
this
video i also reached out to gigg to
include his perspective in this story
but he declined to comment according to
amy the two had been close for years
when they began dating around november
of 2019 she said that things were good
until they weren't which she said began
around january of 2020.
at that time gigg apparently started
acting differently and eventually
according to amy the verbal abuse and
manipulative tendencies
started which she said were a near
constant throughout their relationship
he started being really weird with me so
he'd gone to
canada i believe montreal and whilst he
was there he did
cheat on me in which i only found out
about months later he was really cold
with me just wasn't
talking to me really cut off he'd never
been like that with me before
i was like hmm there's something here
that there's just not something not
right
according to amy in order to cover up
his cheating gig took the two of them on
a vacation in february of 2020
which she said was a disaster from the
beginning
allegedly gigg was verbally abusive
throughout their stay
to the point where amy decided not to
talk out of fear of him berating her
on that holiday just got progressively
worse
to the point where i think the last few
days i just refused to speak
so i was mute the entire time i refused
to
say anything really in case he
erupted again when they returned amy
said that gigg
continued to verbally harass her then
amy said that march 16
2020 was the first time that gigg
allegedly physically assaulted her
she said she went out with friends on a
monday night without gig which wasn't
unusual she said he sent her angry and
abusive text messages all night
she continued to drink with friends and
they eventually called gigg to take amy
home
amy said that things got bad once she
got into his car
and on that drive home he was screaming
and shouting at me the whole way more
degrading stuff
like i was pathetic and i asked him to
pull over
because i was i was sobbing at this
point i was beside myself
and he wouldn't pull over and he was
driving recklessly and swerving and out
and frightening
me deliberately i saw an opportunity
where he was slowing down
to get out of this car so i opened the
door undid my seat belt and tried to get
out because he refused to stop
what he did then was he grabbed hold of
my arm dragged me back into the car
over the next few months amy said she
lost count of how many times
gigg mentally and physically abused her
she said the next
incident happened in july of 2020. amy
said that in july
she and gigg mutually decided to have an
abortion as she
said they didn't feel they were ready to
have a child yet
it was just it was horrible to go
through already because of the abortion
the physical and the mental torture that
he put me through was
additional to that there were some days
i just didn't see a way out
other than i don't like taking
my own life or attempting to at the very
least amy said that she was told part of
this process
included not having sex for a period of
time as it would be medically
unsafe to do so she said that gig was
aware of the medication that she was
taking
as well as the risks involved if they
did have sex including according to amy
high chances of septicemia which is a
common form of blood poisoning
it wasn't very nice in what he said to
me it was very degrading
he basically told me that if i didn't
sleep with him he was going to find
someone younger to sleep with
amy said that eventually she gave in to
gig and one night the two began having
sex
but then amy said she changed her mind
soon after
they started because it was too painful
this is when gigg allegedly raped her
as he initiated i changed my mind
because it was painful and i told him to
stop
yeah he just he completely ignored that
put his hand over my mouth while i was
screaming in pain as he
continued she just told me to shut up
as um his mum would hear downstairs
amy told me that outside of speaking to
a police-provided sexual assault
counselor a few days ago
this is the first time she's spoken
publicly about the incident
she also said she reported this incident
to police but they have declined to
comment on this specific
incident now the first police report amy
said that she filed against
gigg was on october 5th of 2020 for
allegedly stalking her
she said that at one point after they
broke up gig got a hold of an old phone
of hers
and began tracking her through the app
find my iphone
he allegedly showed up constantly at her
work at her home and when she was
out amy also said that on multiple
occasions
gig cornered her in her car there was
points where i'd get back home to my
parents
and his car had been waiting there for
like two three hours
it sounds awfully corny me so i'd be
trying to get out of my car and he'd
get in my car so i couldn't get out of
my car or stand upside my door
of my car so i couldn't get away it was
always that fear of him being there
because he was
stalking me essentially now we're going
to skip ahead a bit in the timeline here
amy told me that over the next few
months she and gig vacillated between
seeing and not seeing each other she
said that she would often come back to
the relationship
that gigg would convince her to stay and
that things would eventually
change but on april 29th of this year
gigg
allegedly physically assaulted amy again
according to amy some of giggs stuff was
at an apartment of one of her friends
he wanted it back and she said she would
meet him outside of the apartment to
give it to him she said that after
meeting him outside
gigg allegedly took her phone in order
to get her
into his car amy said that after she
refused to get back together with him
gigg was physically aggressive towards
her and elbowed her in the throat
when she attempted to get her phone back
police were eventually called and amy
filed her report
here's amy talking about what happened
and when i was refusing he got
physically aggressive again so i had um
bruises all over my knees
and my legs uh he elbowed me
to the throat to get because i tried to
get my phone back
off him so i could obviously contact
someone for help now
after this happened gigg was told not to
approach
amy or have any further contact with her
but then skipping ahead to june
on june 11th a 21 year old by the name
of ellis hindle
was arrested on suspicion of assault
against a woman
outside of a property on waterways
avenue
trafford now amy said that giggs showed
up that day at the apartment she was
staying at and allegedly physically
assaulted her again
she said that gigg shoved her around and
verbally abused her
until the person she's currently dating
showed up
and called the police he came around at
just the right time
and they contacted the police because
they recognized his car
and that was when the six police
officers came into the flat
and they arrested him off that because
obviously they'd seen the marks and
they'd
heard the shouting whilst outside the
door and from him
greater manchester police confirmed that
the june 11th incident was reported
but what's unclear at the moment is if
hindu was arrested
specifically for that april 29th
incident
now per uk police guidelines they
declined to name the suspect involved
but according to email correspondence as
well as an incident number connected to
the report
we can confirm that a 21 year old named
ellis hindle
was named as the suspect and that amy
southern was the one who filed the
report
amy also said that she spoke to an
officer who told her
that hindu was going to be charged with
five counts
relating to abuse now because those
charges have yet to be filed a police
spokesperson
was unable to comment on the veracity of
that information it's worth noting that
one of the potential offenses being
discussed against hindu
is something called malicious
communications
in the uk under the communications act
of 2003
malicious communications in part refers
to
quote a person sending any public
electronic communications network
a message or other content that is
grossly offensive
or of an indecent obscene or menacing
character
end quote according to amy she provided
the police with dozens of messages
between her and gig
as evidence in terms of next steps amy
forwarded me an email from police
that states officers are currently
compiling all relevant evidence
including statements from both parties
from there they're going to turn over
that evidence to the crown prosecutor
service
and the crown prosecutor can decide
whether or not to press charges
now amy told me that when she came
forward with her story
five other women messaged her privately
and stated that gig had been physically
abusive with them as well she declined
to share
more as she said those are not her
stories to tell
the fact that they they reached out to
me as soon as i
was ready to talk about it and i thought
if i don't talk about this now
ev he's just gonna keep getting away
with it
[Music]
you